yes indeed being played Johnny best
though intervened himself or carried off
one of the protesters as they launched
that orange powder on the field here at
Lord there we just had the first over of
the second ashes test with their
Australia batting England bowling and it
was the latest in what we've seen a
series of similar protests at sporting
events in recent uh weeks and months we
had orange Powers thrown on the table at
the world snooker championships in April
then on the pitch at the rugby
Premiership final at Twickenham last
month are now today on the first day of
the second test and there was Swift
intervention as I say with Johnny bestow
himself meaning to block one of the
protesters but he had actually had time
to
um unleash the orange powder on the
pitch at the same time another protest
was also uh dispersing orange powder on
the pit as stewards intervene and then
there was a clear-up operation underway
that was actually dealt with fairly
quickly before clay could regime
obviously the latest in a series of the
climate protest by the just stop oil
campaign and it has been a concern for
various sports event organizers but so
difficult job for the stewards to
actually be able to prevent them getting
onto the pitch
um and and in terms of player has it now
resumed play has now resumed here it was
very swiftly dealt with by the uh the
ground staff here at Lords and uh yeah
play has been able to resume with
Australia uh that thing of course they
won the first test so crucial moment for
England in this ashes series trying to
to level the series I mean I
and fans about this I mean obviously
there's the disruption to to their
enjoyment of the game but but tickets
for events like this are quite hard to
get aren't they and presumably these
protesters are people who've got into
the stadium through through legal and
proper means so they must have bought
tickets
well absolutely potentially so denying
tickets of course for those who want to
enjoy the cricket someone who's actually
in the the long room here at Lord Street
and they're actually cheers as the
protesters were apprehended and then
they were able to actually swiftly
resume the play I mean we have heard
obviously other sports events where
they're happy in protests like at the
horse racing about the dangers it poses
here obviously less so with the more
genteel surroundings but certainly those
who've come to their day of cricket
seeing the disruption and obviously
they'll be discussing here you'd imagine
to ensure there aren't prevent uh
repeated uh protests too but certainly
yeah the scenes are something we have
actually been anticipating across the
sporting summer particularly from just
stop oil protesters with pan Animal
Welfare activists as well
um horse racing but certainly
um it has been something that they have
been trying to keep a watch on we've
heard yesterday from the organizers of
the British Grand Prix at Silverstone
which will be next in terms of warning
protest there against trying to
intervene on the most racing circuit
whether these are greater dangers but
this the latest in a series of protests
which of course a climate protesters say
is necessary to put pressure on the
government themselves
uh and Rob you know in terms of the
actual sport itself we saw with the
snooker for example I mean that you know
that was on the actual
um table wasn't it you know so that that
really did just disrupt the the sport
but but by and large are we are we
finding that that sport generally is
being quite Nimble at dealing with this
now
well obviously the visibility of sport
provides platforms for the protesters to
Target the events it's a way of getting
their message across we end up
discussing it on here and for Sunday
Target Sports for their potential damage
to climate change uh well snooker
championships did have a
company sponsor them so that would
obviously provide a potential outlet for
the cause for protest but certainly they
have been addressing those that do
damage the environment those sporting
events that do so but certainly for
sporting events it is something now
factored into their planning in terms of
how do they try to deter the protesters
what sort of level of dialogue and last
week at Royal Ascot there were no
protests there had been potential in the
build up to that given the fact the
Epsom Derby a few weeks earlier was
disrupted by animal rights activists but
it certainly has been a theme of the
sporting summer here the fact that the
platform of sports is being used to
raise awareness of causes but also
causing that disruption
okay Rob uh thanks very much uh Rob
they're just giving us the latest on the
disruption at the ashes by just stop all
protesters play though has resumed their
at Lords in London